hay temor entre las autoridades y gran
parte de la población latinoamericana
por los aumentos en casos de kobe 19
registrados durante la época decembrina
por ello las restricciones son el común
denominador para este fin de año en
panamá fue decretada la cuarentena total
desde el primero hasta el 4 de enero y
en el país rige la ley seca desde el
pasado día 18 entre las 7 de la noche y
hasta las 5 de la mañana
en ciudad de mexico los comercios no
esenciales continuarán cerrados y habrá
ley seca entre el primero y el 3 de
enero en ocho de las 16 alcaldías de la
capital en bogotá la capital de colombia
las autoridades descartaron el 'toque de
queda' para el 31 de diciembre pero
prohibieron la venta y consumo de
alcohol en establecimientos y lugares
públicos asimismo desde hace una semana
se implementó el llamado pico y cédula
que solo permite el acceso a comercios y
otros sitios de acuerdo con el último
dígito del documento de identidad otras
ciudades se han implementado 'toque de
queda'
en ecuador el gobierno prohibió el
consumo de alcohol en lugares públicos
el 31 de diciembre y el primero de enero
y cerrará todas las playas en fin de año
en perú no circularán vehículos
particulares entre el 31 de diciembre y
el primero de enero y se decretó toque
de queda en lima entre las 11 de la
noche y las 4 de la mañana y en otras
provincias desde las 10 de la noche en
santiago la capital de chile se podrá
transitar libremente el 31 de diciembre
y realizar reuniones de máximo 15
personas pero habrá toques de queda
desde las 2 hasta las 7 de la mañana el
primero de enero en uruguay el gobierno
suspendió el ingreso al país entre el 21
de diciembre y el 10 de enero y se
redujo el aforo en centros comerciales y
otros establecimientos al tiempo que las
reuniones de fin de año no podrán
superar los 10 asistentes
en argentina y bolivia los gobiernos
recomendaron celebraciones de pocas
personas al aire libre y manteniendo el
distanciamiento social